في غابات فنلندا ، يكون جيش الأمة
جاهزًا في حالة
تهديد روسيا بالحرب
arrow 22 تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة
للقوات الفنلندية جنبًا إلى جنب مع القوات البريطانية
اللاتفية والإستونية ،
لا أعرف حقًا ما يحدث ، فهذا
يعتمد على قادة كل
جانب ، دعنا نرى
وما إذا كان البرج الرئيسي
هذا يعني أن الدبابة قد دمرت
هذه التدريبات السنوية الآن مع زيادة
إلحاح
حرب روسيا في أوكرانيا مما جعل
فنلندا تفكر في الانضمام إلى الناتو التي نريد
تطويرها ، وإذا كنت في فقاعتنا الخاصة ،
فلن تطور السهم 22 هو كل شيء عن
إعداد فنلندا  من أجل
الانضمام المحتمل إلى الناتو على حد قول
المنظمين لأغراض الدفاع الوطني
لإنشاء واستدامة قابلية التشغيل الدولية ،
وزير الدفاع الفنلندي
ونظيره البريطاني يزوران نجاح التدريب
القتالي في الغابات مما يسرع
طريق فنلندا إلى عضوية الناتو ،
لدينا إمكانية تشغيل متبادل جيدة جدًا مع
الناتو وأعتقد أن فنلندا ستفي
بالمعايير
اللازمة لتكون أ  عضو الناتو أعتقد
أن المفاوضات المحتملة
مع الناتو لن تستغرق الكثير من الوقت
بسبب ذلك حتى ذلك الحين تعهدت المملكة المتحدة
بالدعم العسكري والإشارة بوضوح
إلى الدعم السياسي للمساعدة في
تسريع تمارين عضوية فنلندا
مثل هذا اليوم يظهر أن قواتنا
متطابقة مهنيًا أو
قادرة مهنيًا  للتشغيل المتداخل وهذا
نوع مهم حقًا من القوة
التي ستضيفها فنلندا بالتأكيد إلى
الناتو.
تتداول القوات من دول مختلفة نصائح حول أسلحة بعضها البعض ، لقد
توصلتم يا رفاق إلى
تجارب تدريبية في ساحة المعركة مشتركة ثقيلة جدًا ،
كل ما تحصل عليه لسماع
تجارب الزعانف بالطريقة التي نشأوا بها
بالقرب من روسيا ، إنها بالتأكيد
تجربة ممتعة و  أعتقد أنه
يساعدنا جميعًا على النمو معًا بعد يوم واحد من
إطلاق قذائف الدبابات على بعضنا البعض
يجب على القوات الفنلندية التي تم ضخها بشأن
آفاقها أن تختار القتال
معهم ، فهذا لا يبدو منطقيًا
لأنه إذا كان لديهم بالفعل قوات في
أوكرانيا ثم قرروا مهاجمتنا
، فسوف يحصلون على ركلتهم الفنلندية على
بعد أيام قليلة من تقرير ما إذا
كانت ستنضم  الناتو
نيك روبرتسون سي إن إن نينيس تشارلو فنلندا
لك